[Music]
welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host Hisham azuz and on this week's
episode I was joined by Christopher
Monty Colombo who is one of the founders
of we shape which he started just under
four years ago with his business partner
Jack we shape is a really interesting
business as they are not your typical
recruitment business they're a
technology consultancy so where they are
today they have 20 full-time employees
within the business 70 people in total
as half of their team is made up of tech
consultants and half of them are made up
of tech recruiters
for any of you that are massively
interested in how to evolve your
offering as a recruitment business and
really get into the solution Focus
selling you're going to absolutely love
this episode Chris really knows his
stuff and really delivered in my view a
master class on evolving your offering
maximizing existing relationships and
really becoming a true partner with the
businesses the recruitment businesses
are are there to help and support
enjoy the episode
Chris welcome to the podcast thank you
thanks for inviting me looking forward I
look forward to every episode but I
think um when I learn about your
business I think a lot of people would
be really interested in that and I think
there's going to be plenty of things
that I know you've learned along the way
and continue to but I think there'll be
a lot of things that the listeners will
be really interested
um and yeah have the chance to learn
from from your journey but I guess
before I ask you the the million pound
question I want to sort of just just
frame it up for people listening in
terms of like where you are today and
sort of where on your journey so as we
were just saying being in the industry
for eight years yeah joined recruitment
when you said you were 21. correct yeah
so and then where you are um as a
business we shape which you found with
your business partner chat more yes
um where you are is you've been going
for four years and you've been on this
journey of building a technology
consultancy or a hybrid you'd like to
call it so it's made up of half tech
consultants and Tech recruiters I have
20 full-time staff at the moment but all
together in terms of the subcontractors
and the people you have involved in the
business you'd have 70. yeah yeah that's
across UK and Europe yeah so I guess
what I what I'm really Keen to really
dig into today is definitely like this
this sort of last three and a half four
years journey of reshape but I guess
let's just we'll talk a bit about the
beginning first but before we do I'd
love to just just sort of hear your take
on how this evolved you probably thought
about a thought about this a lot at we
shape but what what do you really
believe makes up a sort of successful
recruiter today the the characteristics
and traits you think yeah nice um it's a
good question so obviously my time
recruitment was was La Foss associate so
um probably about four years ago now
um I guess the Foss had a lot of high
performers in their business but if I
was looking at a common theme you got
the you got the resilience pitch you've
got to drive you've got the motivation
the top performance were overly
consistent so they turn up every day and
they don't change that kind of attitude
to work so when you get complacent in
recruitment there's always someone else
you want to come along and take your
market share or your position I think
the other kind of mindset is their
communication so the way they influence
and persuade people and that's both ways
is if you look at like external phasing
to a client's had you in over a new
client and tap into a new market
opportunity but also in turn is if you
get the right people on your side from
operations to finance to maybe different
work streams so permanent continued
recruitment or contract design you build
that that team and you um kind of go to
market together
often those people become the best
performers because they work
strategically they work smart and as a
collective they win the best
opportunities that's a really
interesting Insight probably the first
person to pick up on that like I said
like influence internally and externally
yeah I really like that so I guess let
let's just go straight into it so help
help me out with a bit of context but
from what I understood when we spoke
when you worked at leforce you ended up
sort of being part of a team and
building a team where basically what you
shared to me was yeah the force had a
big number of clients Circa 400 300
whatever and you ended up building this
team to look at all of these companies
that they're working with and to
maximize the relationships and get the
most out of the accounts put more
resource on the accounts that needed it
or had the growth opportunities so did
you was you always in that sort of role
did you start as like a contract
consultant I don't know just just give
me a just hand me up a bit of context
but that's not I know where you ended up
isn't that yeah so I actually joined so
under Dave Roberts so Dave Roberts is
now the director of future proof and
digital outcomes which is their
Consulting unit at the time they were
setting up cloud and infrastructure and
I was a resourcer for him so he was very
much 360 delivery consultant overlooking
quite a sizable team
um I kind of fell into devops at a time
when it became mainstream um so I was a
devil's contract recruiter Jack who's my
business partner now is actually a
competitor of mine so he worked for
prison digital at the time so
essentially just built out the devops
recruitment desk
um when it became mainstream and was
quite profitable in terms of building
that that disc jacking up joining
um the Foss at the time and he was my
successor and I wanted to look at
because recruitment for me became I say
quite binary I want to look at the
border border landscape and I thought
the fossa was in such a high growth and
exponential growth within the market
they had so many clients they were
engaging with but they just weren't
maximizing the revenue stream so you
might have 300 clients but you're making
one deal in each placement in each of
those clients and had you grow and grow
your account relationships and a proper
structure behind that so I took on the
key client partnership role this was a
newly formed kind of unit and it was
about how do you build strategic
Partnerships with our our key High net
worth opportunities to win at NFI which
is a certain amount per year or they've
got a certain amount of Consultants
deployed it's putting a single point of
contact an account management team
behind it making sure you deal with
escalation perspectives and essentially
just building market share on his
account so from that I built a whole
delivery team worked with different
units with in the force whether it's a
contract side the contingent executive
Search and you're basically putting the
best expertise together to work on your
most strategic clients now these might
be the a clients for the business but if
you lose they can impact your revenue
and possibilities as an organization I
think the key learning for me at the
time was when you build a business
that's very high performing and everyone
works in I don't know 360 role they've
got incentivized by commission and sales
what we've done at reshape is we've
split the mechanism so our account
managers are remunerated by bonuses and
our sales team by commission so actually
they work together in a cohesive way
because they're not actually trying to
fight against who gets the deal who gets
to so you're actually working customers
best interest you're delivering the
right solution and that was the
methodology we're trying to change up
the force and I think since today the
team's still there and they're still
going pretty well so yeah so I'm gonna
definitely ask you more about that yeah
just quickly I wanted to ask you and
really well put together by the way so
just just two things on asking them
we'll get into reshape so firstly what
would you say you mentioned some of them
but what would you say then are some of
the key principles that you think
um can lead to successful account
development and successful sort of
maximization of relationships and
encounters you think what are some of
the maybe one to three key principles
behind that do you think yeah I think
you need to get the right person account
management
um it's a very different type of
business relationship where you're
actually kind of puppeteering an account
and making sure you're strengthened in a
relationship you're not going for quick
wins it's not about transactional
relationship of like who can get the
quickest deal it's about building
organic relationships where it becomes
kind of self-perpetuating and by that I
mean revenue starts coming in and when
they move to if I see sorry if key
stakeholder moves elsewhere who are they
going to call up they're going to call
call yourself so that's building
authentic authentic relationships second
part is about adding incremental value
Beyond just the services you're
providing so you're doing events are you
actually bringing stuff to them and
learning their kind of business agenda
are they having challenges trying to
find I know Junior software engine
Engineers or is it a talent skills Gap
is it diverse and inclusion and what
you're starting to do there is you're
actually saying look actually we have a
good perspective of the market we can
bring other stuff to you which benefits
you in the longer term we're not just
here for business so I think that's the
second area and I think the other one is
most people Miss is the social elements
since covid so many people I feel stay
at home and they don't actually interact
their customers they stay in new Zoom
calls and stuff which is great and it's
good for the right work in but you still
need speed relationship so we often take
our customers out with client drinks we
try and meet other people and it's a
great opportunity to introduce new work
streams so if you put those three
components together
why would they go to anyone else right
obviously as soon as you start being
complacent that's when you start to lose
that relationship or you dilute your
service yeah some great insights yeah
I've speeded someone about this recently
because we've got some stuff
um some live learning sessions on this
recently a real recruitment mentors and
yeah he called it sort of bridge in the
Gap that social Gap and yeah it's a good
way of putting and you just mentioned it
there love that so the thing like the
other thing I wanted to ask you said you
joined the first one you're 21. yeah the
way that you're talking right like
you're just making it sound like I don't
know just really simple easy to
understand straightforward
where where did Chris cultivate this
mindset I don't know I feel like clearly
you learn quickly do you know what I
mean like I don't know I just feel like
was there some challenges on getting to
that did you find yourself in [ __ ]
I'm really out of my debt fear or like I
don't know how did you make sure Chris
adapted and you and you I don't know I
feel like you could be you put yourself
in situations where you could be like I
have no [ __ ] clue what's going on
there yeah and that's pretty much how I
wrote my life
um I'm very spontaneous in that but I I
if I go back to before I went into
recruitment
um I retok a levels and I didn't go to
university so I grew up in Kent moved
down to London at 19. and at that time
everyone went to University I had to
make fun of myself right so you throw
yourself into the deep end because a lot
of people are doubting where you want to
get to I was very competitive in sport
at the time
um and I want to be a Trader so current
affairs marketing like anything about
the market as I was trying to absorb I
was trying to be a bit of a hustler at
the time
um but what you learn when you're young
is you your business happiness or your
knowledge about commercial all strategy
is my new but you're very arrogant and
you're very confident at that young age
and that's what helped me develop my
career because of the confidence I had
in my own ability but I learned from
some of the best people I've mentors who
supported me
um I had a lot of a lot of respect today
Roberts who took me under his wing at
the force and really developed me and
was quite challenging on me so when I
thought I was doing things right it was
actually look Chris take your time and
develop this properly my first job that
I was quite fortunate it was an a-level
commercial development program at Tesco
so I was a buyer
so we used to buy alcohol for the UK
which is an awesome job at like 20 years
old
um the funny story behind it was when I
should go to the house because I didn't
go to the freshers and stuff but when I
used to I used to get right to House
Parties but I had to bring loads of
alcohol with me and when I left that
when I left that job
um I didn't get as many invites so um
but all those things is they sent me on
on like commercial negotiation training
so that's very advantageous when I went
into recruitment I didn't necessarily
have the the degree and I don't know the
the business
um degree and whatnot
um I had actual real life experience I
was buying like 15 million pounds worth
of stock for Tesco and when you sit in
that seat you have to learn quickly
right because then all that skill sets
very transferable
um and then the other thing is I just
learned by doing so there's some people
who learn academically through they'll
sit in a certain a lesson
um someone teach them something and they
absorb it I don't really learn that way
mine is if you put me into a scenario
over time I'll make a mistake but I'll
learn very quickly not to make that same
mistake but again
um and that's what's helped me kind of
get to where I'm now I love that so
let's go into WeChat then let's unpack
this channel because I know I know
there's been plenty of highs and highs
and lows right so I guess why don't we
just start with like a lot of people
when they start a recruiting business
and I'm sure you have plenty of friends
um within this as well and you might
have heard him say at one point like I
want to do it differently like I want to
have a unique difference in the market
um which I think obviously you guys
generally have so just I guess explain
for us to keep it really simple when you
say you're a hybrid or Tech consultancy
and recruitment business like let's just
start there like how how would you
describe reshape yeah so just from a
kind of high level so we shape is a
technology consultancy we specialize in
devops software data and Cloud Solutions
um and that's anywhere from advisory so
whether it's organizational or technical
advisory implementation so technical
squads that go into do product delivery
or on-demand Consultants so say its
client needs a software engineer we can
service that through individuals and
then the last stream is is kind of
coaching and training so around
especially around the devops processes
there's a lot of tooling there's a lot
of modernization there's a lot of kind
of different Frameworks at businesses
want to retainer existing Talent or they
want to upskill and not become reliant
on consultancy so we coach them through
that Journey
the reason we're a hybrid is back during
lafoss and anyone who kind of does
contract recruitment as a legislature
called ir35 and it was impacting a way
that you customers could engage contract
subcontracted resource in the market
impacted the public sector initially and
it moves into the private sector and at
the time Jack and I and to be fair I
give a lot of credit to Jack as Jack
identified is if we were to blend
um our technical consultancy expertise
so Best in Class engineers in a market
who could validate design and architect
Solutions with our skill set of
augmenting teams those two skill sets
complement each other very nicely the
second thing is as a recruiter you're
going direct to Market so you can be
commercially very effective because
you're not having incremental margins
where some of the large management
consultancies might subcontact to a
recruiter then it goes directly yeah now
you've got two problems you've got a
commercial challenge the second one
you've got is you've got a quality
assurance challenge because there's
multiple people in the process so we can
mitigate that on our side and the other
one is we do everything so we do
statement of work I need the technical
consultants to help me identify and work
my customers to scope out what that
technical requirements are but also
deliverables because when you do do a
statement of work you're underwrite risk
which is very different to recruitment
recruit is very vanilla in terms of like
you're placing a personnel and they
deliver a solution but there's no real
accountability on delivery you're doing
whereas a statement of work you're
underwriting the output and the time you
deliver that yeah
yeah so you need the right technical
consultants who can scope that out and
trust that they can scope it out um then
you can augment the teams of the skill
set that they need so so that that
explains them why obviously as I said at
the beginning yeah a chunk of your
businesses full-time employees that I
think you describe as operations and and
yes you've got operations marketing
which is all our kind of brand because
you've got a number of events we run but
also just to make sure that people
understand what reshape does as a
business
um I got a pretty strong Talent team
um very strong Talent too yeah um who
are all X industry Tech recruiters I've
got a sales team so we do cold Business
Development and then we've got an
account management team and then
obviously I've got our operations team
which look after like timesheets
um our B Corp so we recently became B
Corp certified which is a huge
achievement
um ISO certified which is all about kind
of our cyber security and measures we've
put in place to assure our customers
we're doing things in the right
governance but then that's why obviously
it'll explain why you have a number of
people that subcontractors that are
Consultants within that right okay so a
couple of things here there's loads that
we can go into like really Keen to go
into your journey and selling these
types of solutions and and all of that
but I guess let's just focus first on
like the actual business Journey so this
is the idea this is the concept he said
Jack Jack one and two so
started the business in 2019 a year
before that being a year before covered
right so
talk to me a lot of people think about
starting their own recruitment business
never actually take the leap for a
number of reasons I think a lot of
people don't just quite have the
confidence to back themselves to take
that leap
describe me in that first year mate what
went down in that first year because I
know it was it was it was yeah
there was a lot of highs what was the
game plan for year one so we we wanted a
I think the first six months is we had
an idea of we were very good at
Recruitment and contract recruitment but
we could take it to another level which
was this consultancy model
um what you often find is when you do go
to setup on your own you think even
though I'm an a player and I'm I'm doing
very well the brand doesn't always
follow suit and your clients don't
always follow suit and obviously you've
got non-completes in place so you're
you're pretty much starting from Ground
Zero
um so what we did is we went out to
market the first thing we had to get
right was the shift away from
recruitment so when you're speaking to
customers who typically knew you as
recruiters you've now got to tell them
that you're no longer working on a
margin you're working on a rate card
these are the engagement models
um you're turning that business when you
actually need business because of cash
flow
um and Jack and I had pretty much
self-invested all our money to build we
shapes so we didn't have an external
funding at the time Jack had just had a
one-year-old time so he had far more
responsibility for me who's just kind of
roaming around London trying to make
make this work how much runway did you
give yourself
um we gave us about a year which goes
very quickly right so I think
um we didn't obviously no one knew all
present um expected covert to happen and
obviously the the duration of how long
lockdown happened but one of the king
notable things was we shape used to be
called shape obviously when you're
building a business you're focusing so
much on Business Development and trying
to generate new new opportunities the
funny story was it wasn't funny at the
time but there's a there's an
organization from America who's building
a presence in in London
um they're in a security consultant we
didn't know this at the time anyway they
come around to view offices and we're
based in in Tower Bridge and out of
every office they could view in London
and every room they could view in the
shared office they came to Art and
they've asked us what we've done and
obviously as as young kind of hungry
sales people like we sell technology
consultancy services and we asked them
what they did it and they told us they
were security consultancy called shape
as well
um and obviously me looking at the the
kind of intellectual property in our
trademarks and stuff
um they were like a billion pound
company and we got a trademark uh
infringement wow about eight months into
the business
yeah you get a letter but you've got to
change your whole name your whole brand
and everything
um whilst you're trying to build a
business and you've got limited Capital
to runways so
um obviously we spoke to to Legal
Representatives um and that was actually
the shift to we shape which funny enough
we were called we shape dot IO as our
website
um but we were always going out to
Market shape yeah and so it's probably a
blessing in disguise but we had all that
set up so it was a quick shift across
but these are the challenges you're
facing and they're unprecedented right
so those challenges you've got cash flow
where maybe clients don't pay you in
time
um and you're chasing I remember a
scenario where we we did actually secure
a project and then you're doing credit
checks and stuff on it on the client and
your your Finance provider Could you
um
obviously borrow cash to be able to run
your contractor book
um just weren't able to lend the money
against it so you're trying to identify
all these different bottlenecks and as a
biller we had an operations team to look
for us we had Finance teams like that
and you actually don't
it's only now but I appreciate how much
work those guys do to cover your back
whereas at the time you're like oh you
get to see is your commission check
coming through whereas now you're
responsible for everything
um those are the things that open my
eyes out and if any wants to go into it
I always say like we're always open to
share advice I've got a lot of friends
who have now gone on their organizations
and we share
tips between each other because
I respect anyone who goes out to build a
business because it's not easy but there
are once you've done this multiple times
there's contacts there's networks and
there's formulas that you can use to
really kind of expedite that process but
it's usually not the sales time it's the
problem it's the back office and the
operations and the stuff that you don't
even think about which can implode your
business what um how long did it how
long did it take you to sort of secure
and sell your first luck project then in
this sort of differently like you said
the way that you want to be perceived
the whether you wanted to do you know
the first actually the first ever
project we won was a calling right
um yeah we got a call in there Tina seen
an advert we'd shared
um and it was a teacher and I thought it
was I thought it was a joke at the time
because I've never had someone call my
desk phone
um and I barely knew the number to the
phone it was about two months in it it
was an advisory piece of work
um and so we kicked off with that
engagement then once you get that first
piece of work your your emotional side
goes like we can do this he's gonna make
loads of money and if about three months
later we've got nothing right so we've
gone from like high to a low
um and then you start doubting yourself
right you're like when I was a high
performer before I was doing all this
really well
um why is it not coming through everyone
in the market has a perception that
you're smashing it right no one I know
ever shares the the bad side of any
business they're always because you're
trying to play in this image of look
we're moving forward but this is the
hardest part it's about being mentally
strong and having a team around you that
support that growth
um so I always have a close circle of
friends keep your business very close at
that earlier stages because you need
people who can really really motivate
you and be like support because it's
pretty tough and then about a year in
um we're very close to the end of our
Runway we secured a project so we knew
we could do it and we turned that
project around rapidly I think we turned
it around in two days delivered it and
that was
pivotal yeah what can we just like just
came very close to being like [ __ ]
our Jeremiah to get employed it was it
was it was
I don't know that place but um no it was
close
um yeah I didn't have much money left in
the savings yeah because you yeah I
thought I've got and I was trying to
make it work yeah but my ego was getting
a bit of me is but I had to succeed and
that's to be honest with me and Jack
worked best
um or or respect to jockeys we are when
it gets hard is we do look at each other
and we make sure we're supporting each
other we know each other very well in
that in that way so
um it's about driving each other forward
knowing when someone is feeling the
pressure
um and instead of kind of controlling
that it's about right we've got to turn
this around because we owe a lot of
people
um and obviously a lot of the people are
looking up to us now
um and you've got to have that mindset
if you want to succeed because it's too
easy to give up sometimes but
necessarily not not necessarily is you
also have to have that fail fast
mentality if something is not working
you need to cut it quickly because you
can waste a lot of time and time's the
most important part like money can come
you can get more money right but if
you're wasting time on something and
chasing that kind of golden ticket and
it's not not providing a return
investment you need to Pivot quickly do
you think you could have survived that
first year without Jack
no no I think well the thing is is we've
already looked at each other is we
complement each other really well right
I'm very focused on like strategy and
and building business Jack is amazing at
sales networking he's built some very
successful event Brands right and one of
the most likable people you'll meet
right so between us you practice a room
we go crazy at each other at times
um when you're in like a in a small room
you want to kill each other but
um even if you do have arguments and
stuff we'll go and have a beer we'll
Cecil it and it's only in the best
interest we're very passionate about
what we're building right and especially
now as we've built a very successful
team and a team that we think are all on
the same page
um we're doing this in the best interest
of the team and our customers and stuff
like that for us it's we enjoy the
process and that side as you move away
from I'm just chasing money I'm just
trying to chase that kind of that dream
live which you enjoy what we do as a job
and that's why we why we're doing it hey
everyone a real quick one from me this
podcast would not be possible without
our amazing podcast Partners Vin cherry
and saucebreaker because you listen to
this podcast you were able to get your
hands on exclusive savings on both of
these award-winning products if you're a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out Vin Cherry who are an
all-in-one operating system for your
growing recruitment business with
saucebreaker if you want to make sure
that all of your recruiters have the
best tools on the market to stand out
and beat their competition then you have
to check out Source breaker use the link
in the show notes in the comments below
and you'll be able to get yourself
exclusive savings on these amazing
products love it and then I know you
shared a meals and it sort of made sense
with the way that you described it but
like you said at the end of that first
year you probably
at the end of that at the end of the um
at the end of that first year you like
you said like really appreciated what
the operations and whatever you want to
call it black office did so then you
hired Pat right yeah so I was I was able
to do a lot of the operations and my
operations is not Pat's level operation
So when you say doing the operations
like well so like you'd be like it'd be
like credit chasing chasing down there
or it could be writing invoices or vat
submissions or reconciliations because
you know you're learning and it's a
really good trick because a lot of
people Outsource that right away
um the best thing we did is we tried to
really understand our business because
once you've got that knowledge and Intel
um you sit in like an observancy as your
business grows but you can when you're
set in a finance meeting you actually
understand the how things are pulled
together and how your business operates
um and if any business leader doesn't
have that visibility you are at risk at
things going wrong
um and you you can only hold yourself
accountable for that so yeah Pat joined
us during covert big rest again
um I used to work apart and Pat was also
at age Le Foss
um but that that guy's phenomenal so
what was he just again painting picture
like so what why is why has he been
really important really good at the
hiring why why yeah like so what is he
now responsible for and why has that
been really important to the to the
growth of the business so he's head of
operations for we shape now
um started operations uh lead and it's
progressed rapidly for the organization
um simple bringing in CRM systems um
doing the right due diligence antenna
process behind that
um so we work off uh Venturi at present
and and it suits in a suits the kind of
model we we and the services we sell
um looking at stuff like b cup so really
instigating a business with purpose
um it's a two-year kind of waiting list
now to get onto that and it's about I
mean it's been about 12 months trying to
build all the Frameworks and and the
right credentials behind it to make sure
um we showed a position to to be awarded
it
um it's also about just the when you're
when you're working with gig economy or
Consultants it's all about onboarding
how quick are you onboarding how quick
can you get contracts out because
anytime you make mistakes around payroll
on boarding
um you set a president and a perspective
to Market so if someone's not getting
paid on time
why would they work with you again when
they can go to many other providers who
will when you're impressing data how do
you make sure that your customers and
your consultant
um make sure you have right udpr prices
in place and stuff like that all that
stuff matters because when you scale the
business if you don't have those
measures in place you're constantly
having to retrospect you go back and and
change everything and that's where I
feel some businesses invest a lot in
their sales mechanism because they want
to make more Revenue their back office
isn't built to the scale they need to
get to and that's where they have
challenges whereas we took the risk of
investing the back office operations the
marketing the talent team and me and
Jack were focusing on the outbound
business development side and
fortunately we secured some large and
and fairly profitable deals which
allowed us to then accelerate the sales
side
um and now the back office can we could
accommodate our back office now it's
probably up to about 250 Consultants at
the level we are now so how much so
you're way ahead yeah so what did the
business look at the end of year two
then so yeah two it was about four of us
it was myself Jack
um Pat and Glenn so Glenn was a extra
cruiser third Republic at the time
brought him across
um as a young lad who's and he he was
awesome at the start so really he was a
single like essentially me and Jack
which had a solution Glenn would Source
The Source the expertise we had our own
network anyway so it wasn't
um a challenging obviously Jack and I
could do the delivery if need be but
Glenn was instrumental in sourcing the
right expertise and it was quite me and
Jack sometimes missed the days where it
just kind of three and four of us in the
room
um where it's just like your every deal
your high-fiving clapping where's now we
still do
um celebrate each course but it's very
much around strategic mindset trying to
grow the business what territory is
going to look into obviously we're
moving to New York next year to build
our U.S presence so a lot of it's kind
of Blue Sky Thinking what's the next
three year plan look like as opposed to
every deal means so much for our
business because it allowed us to hire a
new person I'll make sure we could pay
everyone's salaries so I guess what
people would would love to I guess hear
from you then is like with all of this
sort of
experience in the ones you have you have
now like in with the sort of benefit of
behind Salah if he was to start with
Jack again
like how would you approach the
conversations and and the winning
business differently or do you think you
have do you think you had the right
approach it was more of like it just
took a bit of time to build that
credibility get more used to having the
the the right conversations of the right
people I don't know is there anything
that you think you would do differently
that you think would enable you to have
that Catalyst moment earlier and win a
bigger project earlier yeah I finished
this it's a really good question to look
at because one in hindsight
is weaker to one contractor augmentation
work early on which is kind of like
recruitment delivery
um we turn it down because we wanted to
be seen as a consultancy now when we're
running close to the wire on money I was
like [ __ ] maybe I made the wrong
decision right and that's going I told
you I'd
um and that was just more of me thinking
now we want to keep this this brand of
research Tech consultancy we're going to
live to that name and finally off one of
my friends actually was in a very
similar position I advised them just get
Revenue into the business whilst you're
building that you don't need to Market
it as your contractor augmentation but
if you get an opportunity don't
necessarily be look we don't need to
take that business uh when we actually
probably did but when you go into a
solution telling you it's a different
type of cell so the semantics behind it
are the terminology you use one is you
you're still selling to the same kind of
clients and probably seniority but
you're having to instead of a client
saying to you we need x amount of people
and this is what they're going to do the
conversation changes is that we have
this problem we need you to help us
solve it they now trust that you've got
the right Personnel who can help
validate a solution or design what the
end goal should look like so you've got
to change that mindset of I'm not going
in there just trying to find business
I'm there trying to identify problems
that our business can solve right and
once you change that perspective now
you're entering a consultancy solution
based
um sale as opposed to that binary
transactional that we just finding new
individuals
um so that was the mindset you've got to
share the next thing is you've got to
shift your whole brand your how people
perceive you and that takes time because
when you're calling out saying look it's
Chris calling from we shave no one knew
us it was like we thought we're a
fitness brand or a personal trainer
um so but over time that's now become a
bit more prevalent we won best devops
consulting firm so the noise is getting
out there hoping that in in the right
way but it's a lot easier to get on the
phone because people know who we are now
at the start it was back to the old
school days of calling cold calling
um until people were sick of me let's
talk about this solution or something I
think people be really interested in
this have had people on on the show
already talking about uh this and I
think you I know you said the first one
on the terminology I think that's really
evident in this conversation you're
talking about people augmentation
advisory do you know what I mean yours
worth yeah like but it's it's clearly
evident you know what I mean so I think
like you were saying that the mindset um
is different and you said you're trying
to understand what the problem is and
then you're then talking about Solutions
or trying to validate that problem and
where it can go I guess for me in my own
sort of sales Journey the best way that
you can get better at having that
mindset or at least have more of those
conversations you're trying to have it
contrary questions yes so I think I
guess the question I have for you to
maybe unpack some of those could be what
what questions do you think
um how do I wear this so like what
questions would maybe a consultative
seller say or ask compared to a
recruiter that's trying to get five five
contractor jobs do you know what I mean
what are some of the different questions
that you find yourself asking that you
think you know what if Chris the 360
contract bit like you probably wouldn't
be asking this that do you know what I
mean yeah and then don't get me wrong
right any contract from 360 biller
um and some of the people I watched
would be amazing at consultative sales
because you still need to have that
proactive approach if you look at the
consultancy market a lot of it's built
off partnership mechanisms so they might
be partners with ex-cloud provider and
so they get referrals and she used to
say look into this RFP but then it's
quite competitive so it's probably
similar to going against on like an RPO
type model and you've got multitude of
different agencies trying to compete for
the same work
the difference in terms of what sort of
questions you ask first and foremost you
need to are understand what that
business does from a from a technology
perspective and what is their kind of
key kind of priorities for the year so
whether it's expansion into new
territories whether it's we're going for
a cloud in my markets where they're
going for a cloud migration data
migration have they used vendor Partners
before right and maybe been burnt by
consultancies that haven't delivered
against solution that they promised
right so you're trying to unpick
different areas and we commercially
scorecard organizations in a way that
we're trying to identify is there an
opportunity there and can we shape
really add value because if I can't add
value then it's better place but someone
else can support them and that comes
down to what's their budget look like
are they looking to work with UK based
Personnel or onshore resource or are
they used to using system integrated
system integrator is your large tier
consultancy may be using offshore
resources the next one is is it quality
that they're looking for is it around
speeded deployment so look if they don't
deliver exolution by this time it
becomes a real business problem all
right so we're trying to identify those
different criteria and once you've got
that you can bring the right expertise
onto the call so I have individual
Consultants on our team who are very
kind of business facing but have that
technical competency to be able to
articulate to a senior stakeholder if
you deliver this Tech it will allow to
solve this business problem right so I
need to get the right skill set on a
call and I give them an overview or a
list of overview of look this is what
they're trying to solve and then I let
them do the technical dialogue
um to secure the business and that bug
might be like referencing case studies
we've done elsewhere it might be
leveraging things we do in the market
um so sort of questions I would go back
to asking a customer would be
um what's your biggest business prices
this year
um how do you look to engage with
consultancies if you have got a I know
they might have supplies in place at the
moment if they're not delivering at
moment when does it become a problem
um and this is when we talk about
business critical selling right and how
do you leverage your assets that you've
got this is the security because at the
end of the day they have so many people
calling them saying they've got the best
CRM they've got the best expertise in
the market they've got the best meetups
right that's very everyone's doing that
in the Market at the moment it's more
about what do you offer that no one else
can right and that could be speeded
deployment right that could be like
we've done work at x y z which is the
financial services very similar and we
can come in and educate your team right
it could be but they want to build a
permanent team in the longer term so
we're going to apply an interim solution
but we have an academy that can help you
build your permanent team and we can
solve that so you've got to look at how
do you add incremental Services Beyond
just the vanilla product that's yeah I
think people that's going to be
interesting for a lot of people yeah and
then that there's so many good people
and I'm a plug recruitment
but I I've watched some and everyone's
got their different approach right I've
got ways that'll work for us
um and we're constantly learning as I
said is as soon as you become a
complacent you think you've got all the
answers you'll get beaten right back in
the day meetups used to be the go-to
thing now it's podcast now a lot of
people are entering into the podcast
um and and some are really good and got
huge audiences but they're not and some
aren't consistent so you see one or two
and they just don't continue them now
people are entering into kind of
leadership like we've got London tech
leads and people are entering an app
because you've got the right decision
makers there now people are setting up
academies and Tech Pathways it seems to
us because it's about the skills diverse
and inclusion and focusing on that kind
of mandate for a business so you've
always got to be looking at the market
and how did you build a Competitive Edge
and as soon as you stop doing that then
you'll be beating yeah
so let you just mentioned it there
obviously I think that's when I like if
I'm honest with my first perception of
you guys was like clearly yeah Ford
thinking doing things differently so
like the event videos I think I remember
seeing your like website just dedicated
to like your community and I thought oh
wow this is really [ __ ] cool like I
guess like what are your thoughts on
with all those experiences that you've
had what do you think of the
fundamentals and principles of like
building a successful Meetup Community
or doing good Advantage
but like I don't know what's your take
on it like you might not be the person
but like if you think if Jack's been
really fundamental like what do you
think Jack's done well or because like
you said again I think the events piece
is something a lot of people may be
listening to this and I know what
they've already been done like there's
no point doing that yeah for me my
personal view always is I think that's
the wrong way to look at things like
people ask me that now about podcasts or
arm are too late but like for me it's
about knowing like for you guys you said
what your sort of experts and what your
niches are if you start per meter which
everyone does but it's just specific for
your people then that's still really
valuable and still worth doing you know
what I mean yeah so I don't know
anything on there to share because I
think that'll be useful for people and
to be honest you've probably got just as
much experience in this world as we're
doing we've got quite a number of
successful events and the key thing that
made them successful is I feel like a
lot of people say oh I want to go and do
the next shiny thing which is a meetup
group or a podcast and they put together
a generic formula which is we'll get
some speakers but we've been speaking to
they'll get a venue and they'll bring a
tennis what they fail to do is they
don't ask the market what they want to
hear right so they always people go into
perspection is oh I think this is the
right thing I will do it what we do is
we we go out and we say look we've got
cyber security event at London teddies
in November and the way we've built that
theme and an agenda behind it was we
went out to the leadership and we said
look what do you want to see in the
market and what is the biggest priority
for you right now and what comes up to
cyber security so we steer our
conversation towards that because now
you've got Demand right then you start
to ask like who would you love to hear
from
so instead of you just finding a speaker
that you think is good right because
some organized or you might go for the
bigger brand names but they might not
necessarily be the most technically
Advanced they might be very good
organizations and businesses but from a
technology perspective there's the
person an individual there bring that
kind of visibility of what others can
learn from right have they been through
those kind of War Stories
um and that's what we try and look for
is engaging speakers people are very
good and are willing to share because
the other thing is is some organizations
can't share too much Intel right but
when you hear about new stories of I
don't know we had uh Rodrigo from
Facebook or mesh at the moment talking
about when Facebook and WhatsApp and the
whole ecosystem and supply chain went
down yeah I remember that yeah um we
talked about the incident management
side and what was going on in in the
world at Facebook at that time and when
you hear stories like that that's
engaging because everyone wants to know
big brand name
um and so we try and look at those areas
so one is is go at your Market
especially if you're an SME and a
respected vertical so if you will look
after infrastructure if you look after
mobile if you look after data
find a company that is willing to get
behind what you're doing get speakers
that you feel are engaging
um don't always necessarily leverage it
for business right it's always a good
tool for business because you're
bringing
um the right consultants and you're
saying look this is my network and it's
what we're building we're a brand
um I'm an SM in my brand and I know what
I'm doing and this is how I build build
that kind of ecosystem but get the right
species engaging be consistent if you
want run an event make sure you run
multiple events right so every two
months do a separate one it doesn't need
to be monthly in fact I would probably
do it bi-monthly because that's how you
get different audiences people actually
feel they want to come to the next one
because it's not every month and they
can turn away and then once you build it
don't expect it to be 100 people at the
first event either right that's another
thing people do I've seen in the market
is people want to win every time they do
something right and if it's 20 people
turn up they think it's a failure these
take time we've done a devotch that's
been running for about eight nine years
now that's why it gets the audience
sizes
um you see London Tech leaders went from
like 100 people at our first event which
is quite fortunate but we really pushed
it pushed it hard then during covert it
went down to like 20 to 30 and it's now
I'll start to pick back up right we
could have easily given up at that time
if you're like is it working but we
stuck to it because we knew it was the
right thing to do and we saw what we
were building
um and then as you said we turn it into
a content-led uh business so we didn't
just run the events we built London Tech
leaders at i o we then went out to
Market and got contributing offers so
people who wanted to share blogs in
their LinkedIn stream most recruiters I
know have like 20 000 connections now so
you've got a huge tool but if you can
then share and repost what they're doing
it's only given a platform that's what
other people can't offer so when you
build up your thing look at the bigger
picture as you get contributing authors
how do you get people sharing blogs and
articles because then you can read out
to your clients and say look we've got
this I've got this Channel That's
generating all this Intel it's free
resources for my market
um and this is why we're the best best
at what we do
but yeah there's so much Insight in
there thank you
no no no not at all like look I think
you can say all these things it's a
whole different story people taking
action and yeah that's a big thing
that's the thing so 100 go and do it
yeah I think yeah like so many great
insights in there so I guess I wanted to
just as we come to the end then like I
just wanted to
um I think this would be something that
would be um interesting to people you
mentioned earlier around like in like
just working out the best way to
incentivize people around like the
account management sales like what I've
definitely picked up on is it it doesn't
it's not exactly the same in terms of
like the consultancy and the work and
the solutions that you're selling but
there are definitely a lot more
recruitment businesses now structured in
a way where they do have dedicated sales
and BD teams and then they do have maybe
even the account management teams and
then they do have like delivery teams
right yeah and I that is a quite common
question on like it's very easy right if
you're a 360 recruitment consultant and
someone helps you get the candidates a
50 50 split done yeah I mean in terms of
like how you incentivize people but like
yeah just tell us a bit more
um you don't have to go into the exact
like granular stuff but how how do you
how have you worked out to make sure
like yeah everyone is incentivized to go
into the same direction and like your
Camp management team are just as
motivated as a salespeople and they're
all sort of working together like how
does that work exactly so I'm actually
gonna enough a plug is
um we didn't get this quite right okay
right as much as I'd like to say we're
very good at what we've done and we've
built successful business we bought in a
sales coach to help advise Jack and I
about the strategy and and it's about
two and a half years in
um impel Dynamic a guy called Nema and
his colleague Richard came in to advise
us and work with our teams
um and he actually picked up on
something which was when you're
incentivizing your quarterly ties you're
in technical bonus because if we do an
intent if we do it across the group it's
not like the sales team gets to go to
lunch club or an incentive it's everyone
contributes together and we're working
towards that big hairy audacious goal or
whatever it could be
um and it was about our one was about
how do we increase our budget and drive
revenue and so everyone in marketing had
to be steered towards when we do SEO and
SEO marketing it's driving leads to the
sales team when you're in operations
right
um and I learned this when I was at the
fire so we used to do 8am stand up
people get Market Intel we'd all stand
up and try and get the market leads
um so our operations team the night
before will gather Market leads that we
could be think beneficial so X company
is growing their Tech Team or they just
raise x amount of funding and they've
share that through to our sales team so
now they've got different
um lead generation tools the talent team
are sending through
um
Consultants who we think could be very
advantageous to projects we're
delivering so when we're talking to
clients we're always ahead of the game
and our sales team so everyone is
driving towards that Revenue goal and
NFI in the most streamlined way to do
that you need to make sure the the
targets you're setting your team are all
focused in the lines in the same way
what we had done is we had said look
coursely goals marketing these are the
marketing Targets this is the
operational time but everyone's going
off that and then we're setting a goal
and we're saying like we want to
increase budget what do you go for do
you go for your Target take your bonus
or do you go for the goals hit the
incentive and once we'd looked at and
this is where I talk about it's always
worth getting someone to look at
validate because we think we know best
but we're very one-dimensional you're
blinkered by the business you're looking
at and what you've been doing day to day
just having an outside perspective and
going actually what you're doing is
you're going you've got some very good
people but they're going in different
directions bring them all together to
that goal it's been hugely valuable for
us an organization to grow that Revenue
right and now everyone's on the same
page they're all working towards the
same goal and they're trying to
collaborate together and the biggest
type of learning I'd say is is what this
team also wasn't psychology so one of my
biggest challenges was around empathy
when I was younger was I was like why is
not everyone working the same for me
um or it would be tolerance tolerance is
probably a better way to look at it is
some people might go home early and I'd
be like well I'm working till 10 o'clock
and okay I did the great things my
career but I was always like if I work
late everyone else got to failing to
recognize what knife ones is motivated
or has the same motivations as I did and
the way they positioned to me is is
improdynamic it was like you want to
operate at a premier league right you
want to operate at the top of your game
and some of these people are coming
through aren't haven't worked that
intensity they haven't worked at that
pace to give them time right secondly is
get to know your team and be empathetic
but some of them might have family
priorities some of them might not want
to work in the office every day of the
week and such a and as soon as I adopt
that mentality of being empathetic and
being more tolerant of what thing and
getting to know my team I've built and
you start to empower your team this way
you start to build an authentic
relationship with a trust you and once
you've got that team people want to work
hard and you start to see the results
come through and that was one of the
biggest loans I did which is changing
that mindset to be not all about me and
being that and it's good to be selfish
sometimes but as soon as you start to
look at the bigger picture and get
people on board that's when we started
to succeed yeah I love that and kudos to
you mate on having the humility yeah at
that point you know it's not it's not
easy right there's a lot of people yeah
shouting me yeah you know what I mean so
like I rate that so look as you come to
the end here then talk to me about what
what are you what are you guys excited
for like clearly like you've been on
this journey on really establishing
product Market Fair you'll continue to
go on this continuous Learning Journey
which I absolutely love clearly
reinvesting in the business reinvesting
getting advice and help and obviously
reinvest in the business and growing the
teams and those things like what like
yeah like we're obviously still early on
in this journey which is really exciting
so like what are the sort of short-term
to medium uh and long-term Ambitions for
we share them and where do you think you
can take it so yeah so some of the
biggest ones is we're going to be
announcing we're moving to building our
U.S capability so I'm moving out to New
York really yeah March for two years so
a lot of work's been underway to prep us
for this
um we think it's a great opportunity for
the business of a global operation
um so that's happening quite imminently
the other one is we just launched Tech
pathway so this is investing in
underrepresented areas and individuals
um and so we sponsored them for an
eight-week intensive boot camp with the
wagon
um and then bring them through so people
don't necessarily get the opportunity in
a bit of a passive Market is we we've
seen a and unfortunately it's not a
commercial vehicle for us this is the
right thing for us to do right we've
built a great business
um and some individuals with Comfort
have been awesome so one of them Craig
used to be on School of Rock so he plays
like eight instruments we went to some
of his gigs and it's it's quality Talent
um he wanted a changing career so he's
30 years old came and approached us
responsible for it and that guy is
incredible right so we're seeing we've
now got Ben coming through
um who wanted a shift in his career so
these people who might necessarily not
have got that opportunity previously
we're building this Tech pathway
um working with organizations and it
solves multiple different things uh one
is around the talent skills Gap
um the second one is as I mentioned
before diversity inclusion is a very
topical agenda for most organizations
and it's how to really solve that
because I feel like there's a lot of
talk and activity in the market but not
a lot of action yeah yeah and so we're
trying to really instigate that in
whether it's the events we run and
vocalize that but actually do it
ourselves
um so that's a that's a big project for
us at the moment and the other one is
just building our capability in the UK
right so we've got some amazing people
coming for the organization we've just
hired another
um wave of talent to join us we want to
be number one we're going to be number
one yeah number one technology for
devops software there and Cloud right
we're a challenger brand
um I feel like we've got a clear pathway
in terms of some of our biggest
competitors who are awesome at what they
do someone have been acquired recently
and it gives us that opportunities look
we don't have any external
um investors into the business so we can
set that direction
um and we can be quite flexible on our
approach so it's an exciting Journey
um do you think you'd be here like when
you think of that first year do you
think did you always think like this is
where we're here
I'd like to say yeah but yeah you had
some moments where you doubt yeah yeah
there's always going to be yeah there's
been moments where it's like this is
getting scary right
um but as of late we're in a fortunate
touch word it continues
um as I said it's just not being
complacent it's looking at the bigger
picture getting the writer being played
giving autonomy to my team I've got a
great team but if you micromanage you
lose good people
um it sounds like they're managed to get
out foreign
like you said there's been plenty plenty
of wobblies plenty of challenges but
clearly you've had a real commitment to
learning failing forward reinvesting in
yourselves and like you said not getting
complacent I think it's having fun along
the way right
going to work is most of your life right
or setting up a business and you
sacrifice a lot to do it but I love what
I do I love the team and it's fun right
we're not just work work we go out we
celebrate we're drinks we we go to
Christmas parties and stuff
um we fly to Malaga to meet our clients
so there are elements of like this is
enjoyable
um but obviously at the end of the day
you do sacrifice a lot to do it and
anyone and I'll say at the end is if
there is anyone who wants advice how to
do it or want to take that lead just
need some word of encouragement always
drop me a message on LinkedIn I love
that Chris
cheers thank you so much for listening
to the episode I hope you enjoyed it and
got value from the conversation if you
did enjoy it please don't forget to like
share and subscribe and we'll see you in
the next episode